hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his famous lecture what is
metaphysics Martin Heidegger talks about
the nothing and he coins a term for the
activity or the agency we might say of
the nothing what it does metaphysically
in terms of the world of beings the
entire environment that we were
surrounded by and the kind of being that
we are human being design he uses a term
that's in German Nixon which is a verb
coined from Nix right which is nothing
and nicked it is the third person
singular of it so he tells us that the
nothing nothing's we translate this
generally in English by Neal AIT's using
the Latin knee Hill right and this means
that it's what the nothing actually does
now you might say how can anything come
from nothing well that's a topic that
we're going to explore elsewhere the
nothing has a kind of agency that turns
out to be fundamental according to
Heidegger and he tells us two things
about the ways in which human being
experiences and participates in the
nihilistic behavior of the nothing or
the negative effects of the nothing as a
matter of fact he also tells us this is
something really quite important that
here we go that this nihill ative
behavior the possibilities of it are
ways in which design here is what he
calls it's thrown us there ways in which
we are placed in the world so it's not
just that the nothing does something
that we experience the effects of we you
might say collaborate not only with
being but also with the nothing in
certain types of I'm tempted to say
negative but really Heidegger wants to
insist on this term nihill ative
behavior he also tells us that this this
pervades not only all thought but all
being because of us he talks about the
saturation
of existence by nihill it is behavior
and he tells us that it testifies to the
constant though doubtless obscured
manifestations of the noting that only
anxiety originally reveals so that this
is quite important
now Heidegger is going to tell us two
things that it's really key in this
respect he's going to once again talk
about the relationship between the
nothing and the not and negation and you
might say arrange things in such a way
that our role and the role of the
nothing becomes more clear the priority
of nothing and then he's going to name
off five types of negative behavior
these by no means exhaust them you know
there's plenty of other ways in which
nihilistic behavior as we just said
pervades the whole of existence and
allows beings to even be but these are
five that he names and they're quite
interesting so let's start by talking
first about the relationship between the
nothing and negation so Heidegger says
that the nihill ation of the nothing is
what allows negation to to occur and he
says that negation does not conjure the
not out of itself as a means for making
distinctions and opposition's in
whatever is given inserting itself as it
were in between what is given so it's
not the case that first we have being
and then we have a type of being human
being which has an intellect capable of
making distinctions among those
distinctions being the one from you know
the primary one of negation saying not
two things and then afterwards inserting
all of these instead there's something
that's been missing in this discussion
first it's not that first being is given
and then that nothing comes in
afterwards as a reflection of or as an
abstraction from from negation rather
but nothing is what allows negation to
occur
first place he says how can the Gatien
produced the not from itself when it can
make denials only when something
deniable is already granted to it only
when being already is there to confront
it so I can say okay not this not a book
not a type not a nice day not a I don't
crane operator whatever we want to do we
have to have something there in place
and so negation wouldn't get started off
the ground if that was the case so he
says no the knot can become manifest
only when its origin the knee halation
of the nothing in general and there with
the nothing itself is disengaged from
concealment but nothing has been there
the entire time throughout the history
of human being throughout the history of
metaphysics it's always there wanting
being ready to be shown appropriated
engaged with even though we can only do
so to a limited extent
so he says negation is also only one way
of me lating right we negate by way of
the knot which is supplied to us not
simply by our intellect but from the
nothing our intellect definitely plays
an important role in it logic definitely
can be constructed and apply to you know
we think the totality of beings and our
entire existence turns out that's not
completely true but that is something
that we can do
Heidegger stresses however this is only
one way of needing now notice that when
when the negation is taking place this
is a form of Malaysian that is occurring
through human being through design not
just the nothing doing what it does but
us and the nothing together in relation
to being what are some of the other
types
Heidegger names them off and these are
just the translations of them but you
know you can get this across in whatever
you you think about unyielding
antagonism stinging rebuke galling
failure
merciless prohibition and most difficult
to bear of all he says bitter privation
notice that he has an adjective
qualifying each of these we can strip
the adjectives off and we could just
have antagonism rebuke failure
prohibition privation so you might ask
yourself why does he have these
adjectives there to lend them a certain
sort of definiteness to drive them home
what is he driving home he's trying to
show us by using these these vivid
examples that these are not reducible to
negation there's you might say a
different sort of not it's not just
merely the contrast not that not that
there's something else happening with
these not just something purely
subjective you might say an add-on by
the human being so that antagonism would
be in some way reducible to negation and
we're just adding in some filters or
something like that as a matter of fact
privation is a really great example
within you know certain classical logics
privation was understood as being
something different than say denial
right Aristotle talks about this in the
categories and in the metaphysics this
is a very important point
other great thinkers of Heidegger his
own time like Maurice Blondell will will
focus in on this so he says these are
possibilities of nihill ative behavior
these pervade existence right so
unyielding antagonism he says stinging
rebuke have a more abysmal source than
the measured negation of thought what is
the more of this moment than nothing
right galling failure and merciless
prohibition requires some deeper answer
then nothing is the deeper answer bitter
privation is more burdensome if we think
very briefly about what these are like
we were also going to see another thing
that Heidegger is not quite bringing out
because he's just sort of passing
through these on the way through to
talking about other things antagonism
wires something different than mere
negation we can be antagonistic only
towards something else that we Accord a
kind of agency towards but doesn't mean
that it has to be a person could be an
animal it could even be inanimate
objects or the environment as for
example when the wind is blowing on us
and the Sun is beaming down on us and
we're getting irritated about it because
we have to get somewhere and it's
messing up our clothes and our hair and
we feel you know a sense of antagonism
towards of course we can't hurt those
those natural phenomena but there is
something going on there the way in
which we are relating ourselves to being
through the nothing through the Neal
ation that nothing is a negative
behavior that we are bringing to it
stinging rebuke again something that is
possible between people or other things
that we want to rebuke it when we're
personifying them galling failure is is
you might say something on the part of
design interpreting its own actions as
failures looking at itself of the
failure can also be coming in from the
outside how you know our best-laid plans
go astray and that is not the same thing
as negation either the matter-of-fact
negation is kind of team compared to
these merciless prohibition this is a
very interesting one we receive
prohibitions or we give prohibitions
again within a world of agency and then
bitter privation as I remarked just a
moment ago privation is not always
understood as simply a form of negating
something privation is privation of what
ought to be there what is missing and we
can go on and add all sorts of other
things absence for example is not the
same thing as negation betrayal would be
another form of negative behavior the
point is all of these are things which
we bring to the environment
and of being with a capital B we do not
do so only through our own agency we do
so in relation to the nothing and so
each of these forms of negative behavior
can be traced back to the nothing you
might say we are Co causes or
collaborators in the you know carrying
out a kind of labor within being that
allows being to be what it is being
would not be what it is without all
these forms of negation going on rather
not negation but me elation you see how
easy it is to slip back into this old
pattern of thinking about all of these
in terms of negation once again I'll
just say this to bring this to a close
Heidegger wants to stress to us that all
of these are irreducible to each other
and all of them are forms of nihilist
behavior
you